Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan.
You feel like extra.
BAU BAU!
Crunchy today!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for the 89th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Is Moco-chan's voice okay?
Well, today is the 89th episode with the rare raspy Moco-chan!
Is that it?
Crunchy.
It's another FUWAMOCO Morning like every other morning.
For our Ruffians that are joining us for the first time, or maybe Ruffians that are still half-awake and maybe forgot, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us.
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
FWMC Morning!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's okay, it's kind of like, uh, maybe Moco-chan, maybe some, some food kind of got a bit stuffed in.
Like some cookies or something.
You know, kibble.
What cookies have I eaten, huh?
I don't know, Moco-chan, that's what I'm asking you!
I don't know.
FUWAMOCO-chan, are you feeling hungry right now?
Not really.
Cuz you've been eating the cookies, huh?
No!
FUWAMOCO.
Do you have some cookies?
No, I don't have cookies, but there is!
Another Pero Sighting.
Let's... Pero's not up to trouble again, is he?
Well, let's see it!
De-den!
I don't see anything there, that was just a... Wait!
Wait!
This is what Tyler and Misa don't have!
These unique ponds of it!
We haven't seen this one before!
Ruffians, you know, if we haven't seen it, if we haven't tried it before, that means... We're gonna have to taste test it, right?
What do you think, Ruffians?
Should we eat it?
It will give us a tummy ache.
It will, right?
Right.
Eat!
Eat it!
Noi!
Hai!
Ya!
It's poisonous!
Are you sure?
I don't know.
If you say it's poisonous... Ah, it's poisonous, so I'll eat it first, but then... FUWAMOCO, how weak could I get at this, huh?
We can!
Moco-chan, what's wrong with that?
BAU!
We should.
Yeah, I don't think, you know, no pondering would ever give us a tummy ache.
No, not poisonous.
You know, just the opposite of poisonous.
Delicious.
That's the opposite of poisonous, right?
Yeah!
Yeah, and you know, this one looks so unique.
I don't know, it kind of looks like it might have a bit of a nostalgic, a familiar taste to it.
Yeah.
Where should we start eating it from?
The face?
Face?
The wings.
Ruffians.
That's a big bite.
Try it for us.
Why would you eat it for Ruffians?
Huh?
Should I go for the wings?
The wings!
Well, we hope you enjoyed it lots and lots!
Look out for donuts that could hurt your tummy though, okay?
BAU BAU!
Face for last!
Just gonna leave a little bit and then...
Lots of strategies!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians!
We were so excited to share this with you because actually something really really cool went on sale the other day!
It's official!
You can now find us, FUWAMOCO, along with Advent and our senpai at convenience stores all across Japan!
BAU BAU!
And do you know why that is?
Why?
Because Bandai's WeHouse chocolate wafers are now out!
BAU BAU!
You know what?
It was so cool, guys.
We went to go get some vitamin jellies at the conbini.
Yeah.
But instead, we met eyes with Nerissa!
And then we saw the WeHouse wafers and went on sale!
Yeah!
Alright!
BAU BAU!
The very crunchy.
But more important than the chocolate, my friends, is it comes with a super cute holographic hololive card too!
And of course, you can collect FUWAMOCO's cards!
That's the only trick is!
It's random!
It's random.
So you might need to eat more than a few chocolate wafers before getting your original.
Yeah.
And on Twitter I was seeing some Ruffians who had a very big stack.
Like over 20 centimeters of wafers.
A lot of wafers.
Yeah.
But when you do though, and you open it up, you can enjoy it and check out the handwritten
FUWAMOCO!
We bought one pack each when we saw them at the convenience!
And we had fun opening them together!
Okay, Moco-chan.
Don't look!
Don't look please at me!
Okay, okay.
3, 2, 1, flip!
And I got Ruiné-senpai!
And I got Towa-senpai!
Yeah, but actually, Ruffians...
It's not just, you know, it's really fun, but if you look very closely, it seems like there happens to be a good amount of members that have made some spelling mistakes on their cards.
Moco-chan.
Yeah, Moco-chan!
One kind Ruffian pointed out that I made a bit of a mistake on the first kanji for onsen.
The hot springs.
Oops!
No wonder it looked a bit off to me.
Right, right.
No one said anything though.
No one said anything, but you felt it look hmmm.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Well, it should be fine!
Yeah, well, Koyori-senpai, she made a similar mistake too.
Praise is worth it.
That's kind of mean to Koyori-senpai, no?
It's the truth.
She said that, you know, she has a habit of hers is letting her nails grow really long.
But instead of writing nails, she made a bit of a mistake and wrote gourds.
I hope Koyari-senpai enjoys her pumpkins!
I like growing out the gourds.
But, unfortunately, it doesn't stop there.
There was another senpai that made a mistake.
Lamy-senpai.
Yeah, I was admiring her seriously too beautiful penmanship and I was wondering, how can I write such beautiful letters too?
But that's when I noticed... Lamy-senpai!
She made a mistake on her name here!
The katakana, not me.
Me!
It's backwards!
Haa!
Mami-senpai!
But we all make mistakes sometimes, you know?
Yeah.
It's like me... It's cute!
Mami-senpai, Koyanai-senpai is just cute, but Moco-chan's just pathetic.
Am I cute?
Am I cute today, Ruffians?
Yeah.
That means I'm fine.
Lamy-senpai is Lamy-senpai, except here, she's Lashii-senpai.
But it's okay!
Kawaii kara yurusho!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO getting our Ruffian cards!
FUWAMOCO cards!
Ruffians!
Ah, Moco-chan.
If there was Ruffian cards, then we'd be eating chocolate wafers forever.
Get the FUWAMOCO card!
BAU BAU!
It's so cool, you know?
You can go to the convenience store and find us there too.
Right!
Well, it's not just the Ruffians, actually.
Me!
Fuwawa!
I have some good news too!
But first, Ruffians!
Do you notice something different with me recently?
Recently.
Do you?
I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Moco-chan!
I look fantastic!
Extra cute!
I got more fluffy!
BAU BAU!
I got fluffier, like, my foot!
You know, a little while ago, Moco-chan and I, we mentioned that we got something special for our bath that makes us fluffier and fuzzier!
And it's really fancy!
And...
Actually, I think it really has!
We always dreamed about getting it for years and years and years!
And there was also a special sale!
Why are you laughing?
What?
It sounded like you were saying, yours and yours and yours.
Yours and yours and yours!
But now, Ruffians, my hair is so much softer and fuller and also very fluffy!
I'm really happy!
Yeah, and you know, as a demon dog and also as the fluffy one, my fur is very important to me.
Me too, okay?
I guess, Mococo-chan.
But I take very good care of it.
But now, I'm even puffier!
Moco-chan's even puffier!
It makes me really happy.
And it makes me really happy that you noticed, Ruffians.
Please continue to notice my changes and improvements just like you would in a tree in the Four Seasons.
Okay!
I'm not a tree.
I'm a demon dog!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan's voice is fuzzy.
It's extra fuzzy today.
BAU BAU!
I have a suggestion.
It may be you like the normal fuzzy Moco-chan without the fuzzy voice.
Actually, did you hear it?
There's a way that you can hear FUWAMOCO-chan more!
Because earlier this month, we participated in a new voice pack!
BAU BAU!
It's the hololive academy voice pack, The Entrance Arc.
This time, you know, it's a little bit different from the previous voice packs.
It's in a world that's slightly different from our own.
And you, Ruffians, you've been hired to be a new teacher at the hololive Academy!
What kind of antics will we pull you into?
You know, will you do all that as a crying teacher?
And will you school us and make us do our schoolwork?
Nice!
And you see, this is Volume 1, it's the Ending Arc.
It's a new series, so you'll have to check out what kind of, how the story unfolds from here on out.
What did you think, Ruffians?
Do it here!
You teach it, yeah!
He told on us all the time.
BAU BAU
Please check it out on FUWAMOCO!
We're really excited for the next part of the day!
BAU BAU!
And the cute Bijou here is so cute!
How's the nostalgic feel?
BAU BAU!
It's been a little while, but... Ruffians!
We got a scoop on the Ruffians!
Thank you so much to Uncle Rupi for the impeccable journalism!
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look!
Wow, it seems like Poruru-oneechan, she's made an unexpected new friend!
I'm this friend.
He's funny and ugly, and that's why his name is the Fuggler.
FUWA!
Moco-chan, you're not going to get jealous again like you did when Poruru-oneechan gave Mumei-senpai a big hug during the 3D, right?
No, but, I mean, it makes sense that Poruru-oneechan would make new friends, but... Yeah?
Actually... Huh?
I want to say!
No.
Huh?
How do I look similar to someone I know?
It's Fuwawa in the lighting!
Huh?!
I don't look like that in the lighting.
It's the exact same.
Huh?
Moco-chan, are you sure that's not you?
No way.
You sure?
Yeah.
After all, you know.
I don't look anything the same.
Wait, wait.
Moco-chan.
Wow.
It's not the same.
I don't know.
Ruffians!
Don't listen to Moco-chan, okay?
You know, Moco-chan, you really shouldn't say things like that though because it'll cause more misunderstandings.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
I'm happy Poruru-oneechan has a new friend!
BAU BAU!
It's the middle of the week.
Maybe it's been a little bit of a rough week, Ruffians.
Moco-chan.
Do you think you have something that you can give us a little bit more pup?
I don't know.
Maybe.
Ruffians!
Hi.
Are you ready for some raspy motivation?
Did you have a funny feeling?
That today is a bit different than usual?
Well, that's because it's that day of the week!
Once again, it's time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians!
Have you been feeling okay?
Do you feel a bit... under the weather?
Do you feel a bit... Rasputin?
Are you sure?
Do allergies really... really have their hold on you?
I know it can be tough, but despite feeling out of it, you're doing your best to continue.
You're strong.
You're raw.
Nothing is gonna take you out.
But you know, part of that is knowing when it's time to take a rest.
That way, you can make sure you're at top strength and ready to keep going, despite feeling a bit off.
Remember!
I'm cheering for you!
Fuwawa is still cheering for you!
BAU BAU!
Pero... It's probably even cheering for you too.
So let's give it our all and just take it day by day, okay?
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
It's FUWAMOCO-chan!
Hang in there, Ruffians!
Hang in there, Mococo-chan!
BAU BAU!
Let's check out who's the Doggie of the Day today!
For the Doggie of the Day, we have... De-den!
Today's Doggie of the Day is Elrond and Bero!
So cute!
Is it their birthday?
Yeah, you know, actually it was.
But they're not twins.
But they celebrate their birthdays together because they're good brothers.
Look at the cute costumes!
Apparently though, Beowulf wasn't a fan until he saw all the treats he was gonna be getting.
Gotta change things.
That makes sense.
Right?
Look how fluffy they are!
Right!
Fuzzy too.
I love the little eyes!
And the glasses!
Well, how do you think they BAU BAU, Moco-chan?
Happy birthday, BAU BAU!
Happy bir-
De-den!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, I don't think that's how they BAU BAU, but that's okay.
Well, we're wishing a super duper happy birthday to both Amber and Beelzebub.
Please stay fluffy and fuzzy, and don't let the sudden costumes in your life get you down.
What does that mean?
It means exactly what it means.
You know, you never know, there could always be lots of cheats around the corner.
BAU BAU!
Next, Ruffians, you've been going for walks, right?
Let's see where you went for a walk this time.
No.
What's the corner?
Today, I went on a walk.
You got it!
BAU BAU!
Let's see it for real this time.
De-den!
Cute!
Chiranugo!
That's so cute!
Moco-chan, you shouldn't say that!
Nene-chi!
Not Nene-chi-senpai!
Watch out, Nene-chi is gonna get you, Moco-chan!
Nene-chi!
My similar to Ryan!
Chinamekore!
We've never seen them before, you know?
Hopefully, you know, we can go to the clams sometime soon and see them!
Yeah!
We'd like to see what the Chinamekore is!
I feel like they're very peaceful.
Peaceful.
I don't know, there's the one in the front that's kind of stripy and the ones in the back that aren't.
There's lots of them.
There's polka dots.
Ah, polka dots too.
Polka dots.
BAU BAU!
They're so cute, right?
What are they, uh, garden eels?
We actually received a Ruffian.
No Question of the Day we received a Ruffian.
BAU BAU!
The Ruffian quit!
And now, we get a whole Ruffian!
We get a whole Ruffian, Moco-chan!
Now, we got a question!
Yeah, another Ruffian.
Let's see what our Question of the Day is today!
Oh!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Congratulations on the move!
What Japanese foods have become some of your favorites besides ponzu?
Classic Japanese food, huh?
Ordering!
Or any you'd like to master cooking someday.
We haven't really had the time to have a really nice meal or anything, you know?
FUWAMOCO
Indian Club!
Mark in the Northwest Passage.
I know there's some very, very yummy places with authentic flavors, but for some reason, it's sort of better in some ways in Japan.
Yeah.
Some ways.
I know!
Naan bread.
Moco-chan, you really like the naan bread.
Yes!
I know it.
It's so fresh!
Intense!
It's huge!
I make it for you!
I feel like it shouldn't be allowed to be that big!
But... The curry you had... It's super sweet.
Like something you put on ice cream.
Yeah.
Really, really sweet.
And as FUWAMOCO, we're really not good with spice.
We're pretty weak.
But it would be nice if it tasted a bit more spicy.
Yeah.
And not just like syrup.
Dessert.
Yeah.
Not too spicy, too sweet.
It's too sweet!
Yeah, I don't know what to do.
It's like pink sauce.
Pink sauce, yeah.
Yeah, it's a bit of a funny occurrence.
BAU BAU!
Maybe we can find some spicy curry.
But not too spicy.
Because we don't like spicy!
But it should taste sweet!
Ice cream curry!
BAU BAU!
No thank you.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for all your submissions with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMorning!
And thank you for FUWAMOCO's group as well.
We're always looking!
So please let us know.
Oh, today I went on a walk and I stepped in a puddle.
Where, you know...
Oh, FUWAMOCO, I wonder, I wonder if you've been thinking about this and what you think about this.
Those kind of things.
My dog sounds like Mococo!
Please let us know, okay?
FUWAMOCO Morning is a show that we make together, so we're waiting, okay?
BAU BAU!
BAU!
For our next theme, we have... De-den!
We're playing school albums together with all of our fans!
It's gonna be all our first time, but I'm looking forward to it because, you know, Moco-chan, we're demon guard dogs.
We're brave, right?
And now it's time to show just how brave we are.
Why am I crying in the thumbnail?
Because we're being brave, that's why.
We'll show everybody that FUWAMOCO is the bravest demon guard dogs in all of Advent, right?
BAU BAU!
And we take a look at this week's schedule.
Well, this weekend we have our Rock n' Rawr Party.
We are really looking forward to it, but unfortunately, you know, Mococo-chan was kind of under the weather with a really bad migraine.
But it's okay because we're gonna be singing a bunch of our favorite anime songs, so we hope you'll be there with us on Saturday!
But one day before that, on Friday!
At 6AM PT or 9AM ET, we're gonna be doing our first off collab with Koyori-senpai!
We're gonna be doing even more singing too!
We were just seeing on Twitter that we need to run away.
I don't know why we need to run away.
BAU!
We have FUWAMOCO Morning with Koyori-senpai!
Our first guest, so we're really looking forward to it.
Maybe we'll have Koyori-senpai introduce some special corners this time.
We hope that you'll be there to start the day off on the right paw again!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
For Ruffians who are joining us through the archives today, here is your FUWAMOCO word!
It's... BAU BAU MONDAY REPLAYS!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
BAU BAU!
Water blocks!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!